اعلن الجيش المصري عن مقتل عنصر امن
باطلاق نار اثناء مطاردته مهربي مخدرات
على الحدود مع اسرائيل وقال المتحدث
الرسمي باسم الجيش المصري ان عنصر الامن
اضطر لاختراق الحاجز الاسرائيلي اثناء
عمليه مطارده قبل ان يفارق الحياه خلال
تبادل لاطلاق النار
اعلن الجيش الاسرائيلي مقتل ثلاثه جنود
واصابه اخر في حادث امني على الحدود مع
مصر كما اعلن تحيده مطلق النار واوضح بيان
الجيش الاسرائيلي ان من وصفه بالمخرب هو
شرطي مصري مشيرا الى ان التحقيق في
الحادثيه يتم بتعاون كامل ووثيق مع الجيش
المصري واضاف الجيش الاسرائيلي ان قواته
تواصل اعمال التمشيط في المنطقه تاكدي من
عدم وجود مخربين اخرين
قالوا وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي يوفكا ان
حادثه اطلاق النار على الحدود مع مصر
انتهى بنتائج وخيمه وفي تغريده على تويتر
اضاف جالنت ان الجنود الاسرائيليين ادوا
مهامهم بتفان واكدنا ان التحقيقات ستجرى
بدقه وان قاده الجيش يواصلون اداء مهامهم
بعزم ومثابره
كشفت مصادر العربيه عن اتصالات مصريه
اسرائيليه قد تمت بهدف عقد اجتماع امني
عاجل بشان اطلاق النار على الحدود بين
البلدين اضافت مصادر العربيه الى انه تم
تشكيل لجنه مصريه اسرائيليه بشان حادث
اطلاق النار على الحدود ومنع تكراره
ومعنا من معبر نتسان مراسله العربيه لانك
الغاسي لان مساء الخير مرحبا بك معي في
نشره الرابعه من الرياض
هل انتهت هذه الحادثه بشكل كامل اغرق هذا
الملف
اهلا بك الحدث الامري هو يعني بدا منذ فجر
اليوم منذ تمام الساعه الرابعه فجرا
تقريبا ويستمر حتى هذه اللحظه لم ينتهي
حتى الان هناك يعني تعزيزات امنيه
وتعزيزات عسكريه يعني تتواجد في المنطقه
التي تم بها اطلاق النار الذي ادى الى
مقتل ثلاثه جنود اسرائيليين وايضا مقتل
جندي مصري من قبل القوات الاسرائيليه التي
تدعي بان جندي مصري هو قام بالتسلل الى
اراضي اسرائيليه وقام باطلاق النار على
جنود اسرائيليين منهم مجنده وجنديين
اسرائيليين فعليا ما ادى الى مقتلهم ولكن
تعزيزات امنيه تم ارسالها من قبل القوات
والاجهزه الامنيه الاسرائيليه الى المنطقه
لتمشيط المنطقه بشكل كامل والتاكد انه لا
يوجد هناك اي اشخاص مسلحين اخرين يعني
يشكلون تهديدا وخطرا امنيا على اسرائيل
اين تحدث ان الطائرات ايضا العسكريه
للمراقبه ما زالت تحلق فوق المنطقه
والتمشيط تم بعث اي فعليا قوات خاصه من
قبل الجيش الاسرائيلي الذين يقومون يعني
التفتيش المنطقه حتى هذه اللحظه هل تم
اغلاق هذا المعبر معبر نتسانه ولو مؤقتا
لاي اجراءات امنيه او عسكريه او تمشيط
ايضا كذلك لنا
صحيح المعبر هو مغلق كما ترى من خلفه هو
مغلق بشكل تام وكامل ايضا المنطقه التي تم
بها اطلاق النار تم اغلاقها واعلانها
منطقه عسكريه مغلقه تواجد مكثف من قبل
القوات الاسرائيليه ايضا من من حيث
تواجدنا في القدس من القدس الى هذه
المنطقه في الجنوب كان هناك في الطريق
ايضا حواجز قامت القوات الاسرائيليه بنصب
عدد من الحواجز واغلاق عدد من الشوارع
المؤديه الى المنطقه الحدوديه اين نتحدث
ان حاله التاهب ما زالت مستمره من قبل
القوات الاسرائيليه عمليات ايضا كذلك
التنشيط الجوي كنا نتابعها يعني على
الهواء مباشره قبل اكثر من ساعه هل لا
زالت تنشط المروحيات الاسرائيليه في
عملياتها التمشيطيه الجويه حتى هذه اللحظه
صحيح حتى هذه اللحظه ما زالت الطائرات
تحلق لان فعليا العمليه وعمليه التمشيط لم
تنتهي حتى الان كان هناك قبل قليل ايضا
جلسه لتقييم الاوضاع لم يتم ذكر تفاصيل
كثيره بشان هذا هذه الجلسه ولكن حتى الان
على ما يبدو ان تفاصيل الموضوع لم يعني لن
تكون واضحه حتى الان ننتظر ايضا البيانات
من قبل الجيش الاسرائيلي لتاكيد ما هذه ما
هي الروايه لان الروايه ايضا الاسرائيليه
هي متناقضه بالنسبه للبيان المصري
والاعلام المصري يعني
بنقطه مهمه كنت اود السؤال ايضا عنها لانا
يعني هل هناك فعلا من تناقض او اختلاف ما
بين الروايتين المصريه والاسرائيليه وباي
شكل حتى يفهم المشاهد نوعيه هذا التناقض
او النقاط التي فيها اختلاف بين البيانيين
صحيح على ما يبدو ان هناك نقاط يختلف
عليها الجانب الاسرائيلي والجانب المصري
حاليا حسب البيانات الصادره عن الجانب
الاسرائيلي وايضا عن الجانب المصري الناطق
باسم الجيش الاسرائيلي والناطق باسم
الشرطه الاسرائيليه قبل قليل كان هناك
اعلان صادر منهم قد اكدوا بان هناك يعني
مسلح قالوا بانه هو مصري وينتمي الى الجيش
المصري كان بلباس ايضا الجيش المصري قد
تسلل الى الاراضي الاسرائيليه وقام باطلاق
النار على مجنده واسرائيليه وايضا جنديين
اسرائيليين ما ادى الى مقتل ثلاثه جنود
اسرائيليين اما الروايه المصريه تقول بان
الجندي المصري كان يحاول فعليا ملاحقه احد
المهربين مهربين المخدرات على ما يبدو
وكان يعني يحاول المحافظه على الامن
وقامت القوات الاسرائيليه بقتله على ما
يبدو بالخطا
اشكرك جزيلا الشكر على كل هذه المعلومات
والتفاصيل التي وفيتينا بها من معبر
نيتسان مراسله العربيه لانك الغاز شكرا
جزيلا لك
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات